este miércoles mientras Ucrania
celebraba su día de independencia y el
conflicto cumplía su sexto mes la ciudad
de Nueva York acogió un nuevo consejo de
seguridad de Naciones Unidas para
memorar los estragos de la invasión rusa
durante este periodo devastador miles de
civiles han muerto y han resultado
heridos entre ellos cientos de niños y
otros innumerables han perdido a sus
familiares amigos y seres queridos En la
reunión participó por videoconferencia
al presidente ucraniano bolodimir
selenski que denunció que en el Día
grande de Ucrania Rusia siguió atacando
infraestructuras civiles en el centro
del país
he recibido información de que Rusia ha
lanzado misiles contra la región de
Nitro petropsk contra la estación de
tren contra los vagones de la estación
50 personas resultaron heridas por
desgracia el número de Muertos podría
aumentar
Esta es nuestra vida diaria Así es como
Rusia se preparó para esta sesión de la
ONU
los representantes de los países
miembros plantearon un amplio abanico de
Preocupaciones en materia de seguridad a
todas las escalas la cuestión de la
planta nuclear destapolis ya ocupada por
los rusos desde marzo obtuvo un capítulo
especial sin embargo entre Los
Embajadores de Rusia y Ucrania
continuaron los Reproches cruzados
y sus patrocinadores occidentales que
están librando una guerra por encargo
contra Rusia con el último ucraniano se
salen fangando cada vez más en el apoyo
a este régimen antipopular y antihumano
haciendo la vista gorda ante las
manifestaciones de neonasismo
nacionalismo extremo y rusofobia
seguimos comprometidos con la soberanía
Independencia la unidad y la integridad
territorial de Ucrania dentro de sus
fronteras internacionalmente reconocidas
que se extienden hasta sus límites
territoriales hoy una vez más reiteramos
nuestra exigencia del cese inmediato de
hostilidades
mientras la ONU Llama a rebajar las
tensiones el conflicto en el terreno que
ya entró en su séptimo mes parece estar
lejos de llegar a su fin